[Music]
in rage all day news that's me
submitted by Wally Cox one attacks all
occur a man on a train melted down and
yelled at a woman for three minutes
after she politely said excuse me
that makes sense well what country how
do you guys think
here we're stressed out like a
[ __ ] America or China I would
have guessed America to a hundred
percent though she was not the reason
why it happened that dude must have been
going through some [ __ ] and for some
reason he absolutely snapped because I
guarantee you that's what happens to
every guy at home with their wife or
girlfriend some people just have a bad
day and he just freaked out but are you
sure she was polite was she like excuse
me or excuse me
well the witnesses were saying like
shoes okay so this is the situation oh
and this takes place in the UK by the
way yeah I've seen so many muni fights
immune Evite's with some a municipal
transportation places oh there's that
lady the racist lady that gets angry
that was she's like I hate are you a
back rats get the [ __ ] outta my cotton
Tommy and then like there's all these
other videos of people getting mean and
stuff nasty yeah so the guy that filmed
this video I'm about to show you guys is
a guy freaking out he said that there
was a big crowd of people trying to get
into the train and he this dude that
ended up freaking out on this woman just
shoved her out of the way and then she
ends up saying excuse me and then I
guess I the way the story's told it does
seem like she excuse me excuse me yeah
but you shoved her so she can say that
yeah for sure yeah and then he ends up
roaring at her roaring right
I was a roaring don't you shout at me
stupid woman and the last person you
want to [ __ ] start on believe me
believe me I know the lost
here's a small dick is there a video I
said that there is oh let's watch that
[ __ ] no bandit it's kind of ironic cause
Rick is an ad that's of keep calm and
talk clever it's funny because they're
so used to it because the train is like
you around side to side just used to
what was he saying cuz it was a lot of
English that I don't understand did
stupid woman
pretty much what I said earlier just
like it's going off yeah just going off
on her he doesn't have very good
self-control does he is not very good
insults either British people are so
good what their insight was yelling at
her for 3 minutes and then after the
viewing man decided that his
we've done and then he will sit down to
calm down by playing Sudoku pseudocode
chills people out you know when we were
going to Hawaii about a couple weeks ago
there was Australian mate that was
yelling at one of the airport employees
like full-on screaming because he got
removed from his flight because they
said that he was drinking too much he
was trying to prove that he wasn't drunk
by screaming so you're telling me I
dropped out you not prove your case very
well sir that's pretty funny bad we were
just like staring at him like bro people
have to scream at the top of their lungs
in public I've seen like I've seen like
a angry Vietnamese man yelling at an
airport because he missed his flight
oh I know which that was called dr. del
[Laughter]
post office that I yelled at oh yeah oh
yeah better you were the one that was
like this guy no no she was yelling at
people so I yell at her to stop yelling
at them nothing's going in though he's
like that's like fighting yelling that's
fine if you were standing in between and
like he's I don't know like yelling
would you would you feed on that anger
or would you just be like mediate it but
if it's like you try to meet he wasn't
directing the anger at anybody else but
that that lady because it doesn't matter
at this point because him screaming is
[ __ ] up my eardrum and uh next to him
you know so now he's attacking everybody
that's what I'm saying that's right it's
not the lady I'm not saying I will
[ __ ] I'm not that violent but I'm
pretty sure I probably would have
probably started screaming to at that
point because it's like I just want to
chill I'm going to work shut the [ __ ] up
that's what I told the lady she's like
oh this isn't your business and I told
her like once you start yelling and
everyone here is it's everyone's
business that's why all these fights are
always like it's not your business stay
out of it dude you're in a public place
yeah everyone's yeah I watched this
video it was it happened here in the LA
train and and it was like a guy I was
bullying everybody like I think he was
drunk and he was like super like
gangster looking and he was like picking
on this one guy and a guided and really
whiny just kept looking like [ __ ]
getting bullied and stuff that sucks
and then this guy gives him a nice
[ __ ] rear naked choke on side
the [ __ ] same day or a new day a new
guy the guy that was just kind of
waiting for his opportunity because this
guy was making everybody uncomfortable
oh go to sleep [ __ ] that's tired
but those little heel hooks you know he
he got knocked out yeah I'm a military
to know he was just think he looked like
a regular decent person but then like he
was just on the side on YouTube like
watching how to do a rear naked nice and
good though
but [ __ ] gets intense love public
justice like that there's one recently
of a bodyguard and this drunk guy was
trying to punch him and he was just like
and then the guy of course he'd be like
a huge haymaker I just popped him in the
face and just going on here he's like
people just swing like crazy
I like tense situations sometimes why
did they blur him I bet you anything we
can find the video without the blurred
face and then we can post it I actually
tried you know the way that he yells
though is straight-up
nappy time yo nappy time I mean like
when you yell so much Yusef all asleep
right now oh yeah yeah because I've
yelled at people like that immediately
after that much energy
that's that she was super saying it like
vibrates their whole [ __ ] brain yeah I
mean it's like your soul kind of vomits
out and then has to suck back in and
then you get tired have you guys ever
been that angry in public before oh no
not in public
not in a long time when I was a kid I
can't have I yelled at our parking
attendant really looked like one time I
was driving I don't know why was her man
and he's kind of mentally challenged too
so I feel bad not really mentally
challenged I thought he was no no he's
not boring no oh this whole time I
thought he was kind of not there in the
head cuz I thought he had the special
job because he knew our the person who
owns the whole like building and I
thought that they gave him that job
cuz it was like a family friend but
anyways he knows who I am
I waved to him
old nasty guy that used to pick his butt
and smell it or like you would always be
digging his nose outside that's why I
thought he was kind of not there no he
was all good he's just old and then like
he would look at you and just stare and
then like stare you down and and and I
would wave at him like and he'll be like
like he would be really [ __ ] weird
but anyways I would wave to him every
day because that's what I do to the
parking attendants I just waved to him
right
one day I show up I'm in my other car I
don't have my tag and then he looks at
me he stares at me I'm about to go down
and he's like wait where's your tag and
I'm all like you see me every day
take it up with Christian [ __ ]
if you wanna [ __ ] see my tech come
down right now move my car if you don't
want me to [ __ ] go and I was like
going crazy right and then I went back
and I parked and I was like who the [ __ ]
is Christian I meant to say take it up
with anger I imagine him going like who
does honest Paul and looking at house
contacts Christian I was like take it up
with Christian if you have a problem I
didn't bring my chair today and I don't
need it and I when I parked my car I
[Laughter]
swear to God I felt so bad I bought a
dozen donuts oh yeah and I went back and
then he didn't work there he didn't work
there I don't know a lot of people have
problems with that admit that no I know
the the the younger guys if you see that
like reason we look to the office so
much now I don't have my tag now they
understand it's like are you really
gonna stop me but you've seen my car a
million times because they're and
they're always hi
they're like this every time I go but I
don't know what made me snap on that guy
I felt really bad I hope yelling you
said you're singing boys right after how
do you remember yep
yeah you've never snapped that Casey in
public it's not that I'm just once that
was like whoa I don't even recognize
myself yeah he deserved it yeah you know
that last Hawaii trip we went to yes so
on the way to the airport
me and Jess were singing some classic
rock enjoying our time right and in this
[ __ ] guy and a Prius pulls up rolls
down his window and I'm thinking oh he
wants to know directions wrote down my
window and he goes hey man look where
you're [ __ ] driving you almost cut me
off oh so you didn't even cut him off it
was almost yeah I was like really
you just swerved into my lane without
even signaling and I'm all thinking how
is that even possible because it's a
merging Lane like you have to be and
then I was like I didn't even say
anything I looked at him and I was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] me all just staring at him I
wrote down the widow and I was like boom
over right now [ __ ] you want to
fight me fight me and then Jess was like
just shut up shut the [ __ ] up
and then she was like I was like no
she's like it's not worth they were
going on vacation and then I pulled out
the other window cuz he did this this
Prius right he went back like this and
you went like that so I roll down this
window and he started trying to talk
[ __ ] I was like pull over right now
we're gonna go fight you want to fight
why cut me off man like 92 years old you
don't know how to drive and I'm all like
just fight me already and then so he
went over like that and I'm like what
the [ __ ] you ran away hello he was
running though because it's safe I'll
pull over they done they called you out
it's like okay what are you gonna do
like okay even let's say like let's say
I did do something wrong maybe I maybe I
was careless maybe
I did cut them up sorry right but what's
the point of [ __ ] yelling at people
and being aggressive with them if you're
not gonna buy if you're not gonna fight
them just pull down just I would have
been totally with fire with hey I'm not
sure you know but I I think you cut me
off man you got to drive be a little
more aware or whatever I'll be like cool
I'm sorry man maybe I did I don't know
did that yelling out of a window though
cuz you have to make sure no he was
insulting me he was calling me like
idiot and stuff like that today what the
attitude yeah it was just like why don't
you [ __ ] look won't you learn how to
drive this kind of attitude alright
breathe yeah in a Prius a peppermint
that's the one time jovial actually
thought about leaving me when I did I
say to you my car dude it wasn't right
because I just snapped it's LA in San
Gabriel you have to be angry when you
drive and it just was like calm down
we're going to vacation were gonna
Hawaii don't worry
what's dope with her though is she's not
trying to pull me back like secretly
she's fighting him while she's calming
me down so she's like why don't you shut
up won't you shut the [ __ ] up leave it
[Laughter]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] your punk ass [ __ ]
hope you guys enjoyed that episode of JK
news make sure to stay connected because
we're constantly updating our social
media so follow us at JK films for
Instagram and at JK films for Twitter to
watch more videos click right over here
[Music]
you